[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
bonjour nous sommes ravis de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui pour le 9e
déjeuner de livres in business club
nous accueillons aujourd'hui au golf de
la boulie un avis tu es complètement
exceptionnel bonjour jérôme kerviel ravi
d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui
merci infiniment d'être avec nous
propose de d'applaudir pour l'accueillir
et nous donner du courage
[Applaudissements]
bonjour jérôme merci infiniment d'être
là nous avons préparé cette présentation
l'objectif que nous avons discuté
ensemble c'est vraiment de parler d'un
parcours humain le parcours d'une
personne et je te poser quelques
questions et tu as été très direct très
clair je sais qu'il ya une seule
question que je ne peux pas posée je ne
la proposerai pas tout à l'heure il y
aura une slide qu'il évoquera mais je ne
la poserai pas sinon vous et des
libertés et je vous encourage à être
direct et tu as accepté de à toutes les
questions
safa bout alors moi j'ai une question
sur sur toi c'est à dire ton parcours
qu'est ce qui t'a amené dans l'univers
des banques c'était quoi
une envie une passion une des capacités
comment on recommence ça s'est passé
c'est un peu par hasard en fait j'ai
fait toutes mes études en bretagne dans
un petit village qui s'appelle pour la b
jusqu'au bac
j'étais passionné de mater l'économie
c'est la seule chose qui était ado très
évidente pour moi à cette époque là et à
l'issue du bac
je me suis demandé ce que j'allais faire
donc je suis orienté vers une filière
économique était ma première passion et
l'économie alliés également les maths
donc du coup j'étais pleinement épanouie
dans ce domaine et puis assez rapidement
ce qui m'a manqué à la fac c'était la
pratique le côté un peu trop théorique
assez rapidement fatigué et dont je me
suis orienté vers ce que d'après la nuit
huppée site universitaire
professionnalisé qui alliait formation
théorique et pratique notamment beaucoup
de stages et j'ai fait mon premier stage
est générale à nantes dans ce cursus au
département titre et ça m'a beaucoup plu
et je voulais complètement arrêté mes
études est rentré dans le milieu
professionnel s'est immédiatement et ma
responsable de stage m'a interdit m'a
dit non non tu fais comme un bac + 5
donc un peu à larache j'ai présenté une
candidature à lyon pour faire un des ss
ce que j'ai fait en fait de ces
organisations et contrôler les activités
de marchés financiers et on arrive à
cette époque en l'an 2000 où les banques
recrutent à tour de bras et notamment
salle des marchés tous les métiers liés
à la salle de marché et donc j'ai
intégré j'ai une offre enfin j'ai
plusieurs offres en fait la luciole
informations mais au bout du premier
rendez-vous en fait c'était généralement
embaucher
directement au middle office et j'ai
sans me poser réellement de question de
plan de carrière où que ce soit d'autre
ggd engagé à sté générale en 2001 alors
ce que je propose au long de notre
échange c'est d'éclairer quelques termes
parce que moi j'avoue je suis entre
novices alors depuis une semaine je
daigne dans cet univers donc j'ai appris
des mots mais si tu veux bien
quelquefois éclairer là tu as utilisé un
mot qui a été embauché pour me deleu
finissent de l'office alors qu'est ce
donc
le minot fils et la partie en fait c'est
tout c'est finalement revient aux
charges de support des traders en salle
des marchés
le back office lui des pouilles et
traite de façon administrative toutes
les opérations qui seront effectués par
les traders et réconcilie les opérations
de la salle des marchés avec les
dépositaires qui tiennent les comptes de
la banque en titres ou en cash et moi je
tiens en fait entre les deux en fait à
faire le tampon entre le back office et
des traits le trader donc tu fais une
entrée classique assez classique avec
eux surtout absolument jamais l'idée de
d'exercer un jour le métier de trader
parce qu'en fait j'avais un bac + 5
certes mais en salle des marchés
particulièrement en france
le profil des traders c'est
exclusivement pour ne pas dire
uniquement centrale polytechnique les
mines dont des grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs
côté commercial c'est plus du hec qui
m'ont prend ou du sciences po ou
économique de cours donc en ayant
approché universitaire y avait quasiment
aucune chance qu'un jour je devienne
trader et d'ailleurs je n'avais
absolument pas l'envi même si la matière
me fascinait même si l'ambiance salle
des marchés mais fascinait
je me disais ça ne se produira pas donc
c'est quelque chose qui était dans mon
référentiel à l'époque
alors comment ça se passe alors comment
justement l'évolution se produit et
c'est
a priori c'était assez satisfait du
travail que je fournissais nominé
d'office et je passais énormément de
temps en fait au bureau très peu de
vacances beaucoup d'engagement en fait
dans auprès des traders dont j'étais en
charge et surtout j'avais quelque chose
que j'avais appris sur le tas parce
qu'en fait c'est quelque chose qui était
primordial en salle des marchés c'est
savoir développer informatiquement
notamment en ses envies aux basiques
donc j'ai appris tout seul j'ai bossé
soirs et week-ends pour apprendre ce
langage est du coup assez rapidement je
me suis de plus en plus spécialisés là
dedans et donc beaucoup de traders me
demandait de développer pour des outils
assez rapidement pour qu'ils puissent
plus rapidement passer leurs opérations
ou prend prendre des décisions
d'investissement sur sur les algorithmes
qu'ils auraient voulu mettre en place et
à la faveur de l'explosion de l'activité
sur laquelle je travaillais très bons du
trésor pour laquelle je travaillais un
poste s'est libéré et assez
naturellement n'ont pas naturellement
mais ils l'ont proposé donc ils sont
venus un jour ils m'ont dit tiens on a
un poste
on veut que tu viennes bosser avec nous
sur ce poste là je n'ai même pas eu le
choix en fait c'est le genre de choses
qu'on peut pas dire non déjà un trader
en dit pas non mais en plus c'est un
poste qui était très courtisé je me
disais bon génial et donc j'ai commencé
à faire du trading
en fin 2004 là tu étais déjà dans les
tours de la défense j'ai toujours tout
fait toute ma carrière dans les tours de
2000 à 2008 j'étais dans les tournants
de la sté générale et dont on fait
depuis 2004 je passe du middle office au
front office ou non là je suis sur le
desk de trading avec les traders et je
commence à opérer pour l'équipe parce
que là on peut dire que tu touche
quelque part une sorte de rêve puisque
tu le disais tout à l'heure c'était
l'ambition que tu penses pas justement
c'était pas mal parce que je pensais pas
que ça aurait été quelque chose de
possible même si le évidemment quand je
les regardais ça me faisait envie mais
donc je touche pas un rêve je trouve
quelque chose qui est très inattendu il
fait évidemment plaisir et qui
intellectuellement surtout contrairement
à une tâche de middle office ou back
office qui est très répétitive est très
relative
là en l'occurrence une journée ne
ressemble jamais à une autre et donc il
ya cette émulsion émulation en fait
intellectuelle qui est beaucoup très
très très présente
et puis le stress l'adrénaline qui est
lié au métier nous y sommes ok et jusqu
aux gens tout ce que nous entendons
c'est aussi une vie quasiment dédia sa
dessus par les deux week-ends de soirée
là ça veut dire c'est quoi ces des
semaines les horaires c'était j'arrivais
à 6h30 le matin à la banque et je
partais rarement avant minuit une heure
[Musique]
pas de nom n'y a pas la place
enfin je n'avais pas la place mais en
tout cas en fait dans la façon dont
j'avais géré cette expérience là en fait
effectivement je vivais exclusivement
pour la banque et d'une certaine façon
ma famille c'était la banque il est
aussi impression au fait qu'ils étaient
donnés en salle des marchés
ce que j'ai pu observer les échanges que
j'ai pu avoir avec d'autres personnes
par ailleurs effectivement on passe
beaucoup de temps sur place et
qu'effectivement on se rend compte que
les gens finissent plus par sortir et se
voir le week-end entre traders plutôt
que leur propre copains ou d'autres
secteurs
c'est un conte sanguin alors que ce qui
est important pour nous parce que il ya
peut-être des personnes pour qui c'est
un univers plus plus familier mais en
tout cas moi j'avoue avoir découvert
beaucoup de sujets tu nous a tendu une
perche et en parlant des traders si on
refuse pas un trader peut étayer un peu
plus ça ça veut dire quoi c'était des
gens qui ont de pouvoir
disons qu'en fait moi c'est que j'ai
entendu à l'époque quand j'ai cautionné
intégrer ces général et notamment la
salle des marchés quand j'étais dans mes
fonctions plus support avant d'être
traders dont deux fois où j'ai entendu
je te demande de faire ça tu fermes ta
gueule par contre la trinité mon propos
tu fermes ta gueule tu es un centre de
coûts non un centre de profit c'est ça
en fait
le schéma dans lequel le on n'est pas
loin de l'image qu'on voit dans certains
films ou ayant fait qu'est-ce qui est
très marquée en fait c'est que c'est le
centre de profit sa démarche et son
antre du coup c'est tout le reste
donc il ya un instant dont effectivement
sur les autres fonctions support qui est
très marquée donc là si nous poursuivons
ton ascension puisque là ce que nous
entendons c'est vraiment une vie dédiée
à sa une ascension qu'elle est là
l'étape suivante est la suivante en fait
pendant pendant trois ans donc j'ai un
peu de trois ans j'ai exercé ce métier
en faite le
ce qui s'est passé si j'étais une ati
sur une activité qu'on appelle le market
making c'est à dire qu'en fait la banque
émettait des produits financiers et
charge à moi en fait de faire
l'animation de ces produits sur les
marchés financiers donc de produire
fournir continuellement des prix à
l'achat et à la vente
ça c'était ma première partie
d'activités et à côté cette activité il
y avait une activité pour dit pour
compte propre c'est à dire qu'il ya une
partie de l'argent en fait une enveloppe
qui est dédié à faire de la spéculation
charge à nous de l'événement de faire et
de faire fructifier cet argent là donc
je propose c'est en traînant des secrets
mais pour des ordres de grandeur pour
nous à l'époque quand j'ai commencé
c'était le lot on peut y mettre dix
roses et des 10 millions d'euros à
l'époque par jour donc voilà donc du
coup ne nous j'avais cette activité jeux
que j'ai opéré pendant trois 3 ans avec
évidemment des objectifs financiers
parce qu'au fait chaque trader un
objectif financier un pinel pinel à 1
réalisée avant la fin de l'année donc on
a fait la première année j'avais un
objectif de 3 millions d'euros à la
faveur des opérations spéculatives en
effet 5 en fin d'année ce qui lui
arrivait dans toutes les sociétés
j'imagine en fait on fait un entretien
de fin d'année pour voir si tout s'est
bien passé si les objectifs sont
atteints ou qu'on me dit c'est vachement
bien tu avais trois affaires d'un effet
5 mai prochain du fra 5
je suis ok donc moi je savais un petit
peu comment j'avais fait les cinq
spéculant notamment énormément les
valeurs des autres traders
c'est quoi ça dépend des activités des
produits qui seront traités donc ça peut
être ça peut être long très très
variable moi j'étais vraiment sur des
produits de flux
donc petite marge et gros volume où il
fallait effectivement c'est un métier de
centimes east mais c'est des volumes qui
vont faire l'argent
et donc en fait assez rapidement c'est
plus l'activité de spéculation en fait
qui est plus intéressante et plus
lucrative avec le risque qui va avec
évidemment les longues l'année suivante
en fait nous sommes en 2006 jeux d'eau
canaux et 6 5 millions d'euros on me
demande de refaire 5
eh bien je prends plus d'habitude que
l'année précédente je prends plus de
confiance en moi aussi et en fin d'année
je vais je réalise 12 millions d'euros
donc fin d'année on me dit c'est super
bien ce que tu as fait tu feras 12
l'année prochaine
d'où là je me rends compte que je pense
dans un sac un peu vicieux quand même si
vous doutez bien que si vous faites pas
les 12 années suivantes on vit à bata
sous performé et donc c'est une arrivée
en 2007 2007 je change de marché enfin
surtout de produits en fait j'arrive sur
ce qu'on appelle les produits dérivés en
fait un fort effet de levier notamment
seraient pas les produits d'aidé futur
indice et je travaillais sur le marché
allemand français anglais et tous là
tous les tweets et scandinaves et donc
je commence à apprendre plus days à
prendre des positions assez importante
des ordres de grandeur à sur le début
d'année en fait je dois être une
position à 600 millions d'euros qui
partent pas bien au début et qui assez
rapidement se retourne début janvier en
fait et j'ai débouclement d'année avec
un gain un gain de 25 millions d'euros
et la caisse il se passe dans la tête
parce que l'échelle bazzo avec un moyen
à ce moment-là je me dis déjà le premier
réflexe que j'ai en fait fin janvier
c'est que j'ai 12 à faire j'en ai fait
25 jeux content qu'on avait fini et je
me rends compte par la suite que j'ai
vraiment ennuyer donc du coup je
continue à prendre des positions que je
j'ai une analyse une stratégie qui est
en place à ce moment là j'y crois à fond
donc je commence à remonter nouvelle
position me disant de toute façon si on
monte des positions ça c'est reprendre
des positions invest-at prendre des
risques donc
j'anticipe en fait une baisse d'une des
marchés financiers parce que je pense
qu'il va y avoir une crise il y avait
beaucoup de tension à l'époque au
premier trimestre 2007 et dont je
spécule à la baisse on espère en dons
que le marché va s'écrouler
le marché ne s'écroule pas 2
mars à juillet je perds de l'argent je
perds énormément d'argent ils pensent
qu'en fait je continue à monter la
position qui va arriver à une position
et là je me mets moi-même en fait dans
un schéma en fait de fuite en avant
déjà à ce moment là la position en fin
juillet vais attendre trente 30
milliards d'euros
et je perds en lattes en 2007
donc à ce moment là évidemment vous avez
des journées qui sont un peu compliqué
parce que tout chaque seconde que dieu
fait en fait vous demander la position
de la coupe de la garde est ce que je
crois à perdre je continue donc c'est un
conflit permanent en fait de la tronche
et enfin
fin juillet début août le marché se
retourne complètement et en l'espace de
quelques heures je passe de - 2
milliards celle de pertes latentes à 500
millions d'euros de gains donc là c'est
un gros soulagement parce qu'en fait
j'ai porté la position pendant plusieurs
mois dont plusieurs mois où j'ai pas
dormi
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête le
corps l'esprit
no stress complètement négative à une
excitation est en fait le paradoxe et je
le dis avec le recul à nice qui était la
mienne
respectivement sais je me rends crois
qu'en fait en termes d'adrénaline en
termes d'émotion finalement les deux
phases sont grisantes
et c'est aussi paradoxale que ça en fait
et non pas que je sois maso mais je
pense avoir eu autant de sensations
différentes certes au moment où ça perd
de l'argent que concernant j'ai gagné
alors évidemment le retournement c'est
ce qu'on attend ce qu'on est là pour
faire de l'argent mais je me rends
compte avec le recul que les émotions
qui m'ont traversé était tout aussi
forte d'à côté comme de l'autre et la
libération le jour où ça se retourne et
donc là en fait je suis fin fin août la
position et des boucles et je suis à
plus 500 millions de 500 millions
d'euros 10 ans je reprends une position
millions d'euros de gains je reprenne
position mois d'octobre juste une
question alors moi l'idée c'est le cas
évoqué tous les deux ensemble si c'est
pas de rentrer dans une un
positionnement c'est comprendre
objectivement ce qui se passe j'entends
beaucoup je prends une position je
débloque
on parle de milliards d'euros donc là
jérôme est tout seul pour faire ça enfin
je vire avis sur les boutons et hop
alors effectivement chez moins deux
milliards de dosettes derrière mon
ordinateur est évidemment à prendre les
positions parce qu'en fait c'est
électronique par contre vous vous doutez
bien que
tout est contrôlé de a à z tout est
dépouillé et puis surtout au quotidien
vous avez des paiements opéré donc en
fait les deux milliards sept de pertes
latentes s'il ya ce qu'on appelle au
quotidien des appels de marge parce que
la bourse demande une garantie quand la
paire soit couverte donc les 2 milliards
7 par exemple à l'époque on était payé
par la banque
ta bourse et c'est pas moi qui ai fait
le virement donc effectivement pantin de
taxer d'avoir fait moi me le virement
mais donc voilà donc et puis les
contrôles il ya vraiment des arrêtés
comptables qui sont mensuelles et qui va
au mois de juin en fait là où je perdais
on l'attend en fait pas mal d'argent
il ya un arrêté semestriel qui est passé
avec des commissaires aux comptes qui
ont aussi validé les comptes et à ce
moment là beaucoup de questions nous a
été posée un moyen mais chef à ce
moment-là et l'instruction qui m'a été
dit ces moments-là s'est débrouillé pour
que ça passe donc c'est à ce moment là
je me suis débrouillé pour que ça passe
donc on invente une grosse pression
expression nourault spip services de
contrôle qui croient qu'ils croient pas
après sa célèbre au débat on a eu
pendant des années qu'on a toujours
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il se trouve que
le truc qui ont été validés ce que je
propose c'est que nous avons là la
chance d'avoir un ancien inspecteur way
dans une précédente vie laurent
effectivement j'ai eu je suis la chance
de d'approcher ce monde et même de très
près parce que j'ai été également projet
une salle de marché une banque
concurrente et inspecteurs qui est la
police de la banque que j'ai quittée en
en 81 18 pour devenir entrepreneur j'ai
suivi cette histoire avec beaucoup
d'émotion et j'ai pas compris
j'ai pas compris comment mais ça a été
un sujet après qu'on a retrouvé
effectivement dans la presse mais j'ai
pas compris comment vous avez pu être
aussi seul
alors moi en tant qu ancien inspecteur
quand je vois le travail qu'on faisait
et et l'inspection passé sur la salle de
marché passe quand on voit le contrôle
de la banque
sur l'ensemble des comptes c'est de tous
les comptes et et heureusement que que
ça existe pour garantir bien sur la
solvabilité de la banque
et les règles sont extrêmement fortes et
ce seront d'ailleurs accru et vont
continuer avec une nouvelle nouvelle
réglementation bâle mais comment parce
que là ma question c'est est-ce que tu
pas senti seul et pourquoi il n'y a pas
eu ce contrôle ouzou ce interne c'est ça
toujours été une question qui a été
posée par les journalistes
et ça ça j'ai lu dans les réponses mais
ça m'intéresse d'avoir un loto vous
savez j'ai des souvenirs surtout des
souvenirs de regard oui de
questionnements entre moi et mes
supérieurs à certains moments ce cas
évidemment tous moyens formé en tant que
quasiment un temps réel parce que le
délai dont la salle des marchés c'est la
milliseconde donc leur en temps réel ils
savent exactement tout ce qui se passe
ils ont surtout les outils de monitoring
pour voir ce qui se passe les
engagements qui sont pris et surtout au
moment des arrêtés comptables ou
des erreurs tabilité se reçoivent et si
également des mails et des réunions qui
ont en fait autour des appels et
passerelles comptable la première fois
on m'a dit que tu es bien pour faire
passer le truc en comptabilité donc ils
ont passé de l'opéra ce qu'on appelle
les opérations diverses en comptabilité
ça se sait pas comment ils se
débrouillaient mais ils l'ont fait sur
la base de quoi je ne sais pas bien non
plus et par la suite en fait j'ai senti
un management en fait qu'ils aient a
disparu dès qu'il y avait un problème
mais qui restait très à l'écart en fait
à chaque fois javier bernat ta vie on a
un problème sur la passerelle de ce mois
ci je sais pas comment j'ai une enquête
eurex de la bourse allemand aussi à deux
reprises
vu les volumes que ''c'était négocier la
bourse allemand s'est inquiété de la
stratégie qui était sous jacentes à ces
volumes ans parce que c'était plusieurs
milliards d'euros
la réponse est signé par mon chef est la
réponse et moi qu'il est rédigé et le
déontologue et une instruction que
j'avais c'est te donne pas la stratégie
tous les ans film évidemment quand tout
cela explose et que
les gens sont interrogés en ligne ou 10
minutes j'ai pas compris j'ai pas le
temps j'étais à new york - où j'allais
piscine où j'ai pas compris j'ai pas eu
paragraphe 2 du même âge passent la côte
et je suis désolé le fait est que
beaucoup moi j'ai ressenti c'est
effectivement vous parlez de solitude
effectivement j'ai eu une énorme
solitude à ce moment là avec
l'obligation de faire tout ce qui était
en mon pouvoir pour que ça passe parce
que c'était aussi mon intérêt du micro
romane dont tu as une voix de stentor
donc bonjour gérant du jour on sait déjà
un croisé un tout petit peu moi je
trouve je vous trouve un type bien
un petit mot gentil non non non je
décore avec vous non non
entre deux succès les chais qui a un
fils il ya un fil c'est vraiment très
fin et ce que vous me disiez tout à
l'heure c'est que il y avait le succès
en fait vous aviez le succès et vous
étiez regardez vous étiez soutenu dans
le succès peut-être pas dans l'échec
parce que tout le monde s'est défaussé
et dans le succès vous étiez seul c'est
à dire que vous n'êtes pas posé la
question va moi moi je me pose toujours
la question quand je gagne je m'inquiète
dire que non mais c'est souvent aussi
propre aux joueurs de poker je sais pas
ce que je voudrais pas qu'il en mais
vous n'êtes pas joueur mais souvent les
gens sont vraiment jusqu'au boutiste
dire que il gâte
il ne voit pas les chèques et voit que
le gain en même temps question mais là
vous avez raison on connaît ça non mais
c'est elle va y venir
pourquoi vous avez été aussi abandonné
pourquoi il n'y a pas eu quelqu'un qui
n'a pas qui nous a pas dit à un moment
stop tu as aussi dans le succès
pareilles méthodes succès je parle de
toi
le succès repose jamais la caisse que là
on entendait des chiffres de trader
moyen 3 5 millions ce que j'entendais 5
millions d'euros à ses maîtresses que
bon j'ai beaucoup étudié le sujet ou pas
ce n'est pas cette saison c'était
anormal audiard dans plus d'un milliard
de réussir un risque et autant il ya eu
de la chance il y avait un coup de
chance monsieur de gâvres il faut
toujours mais voilà mais dans l'autre
sens alors je vais parce que j'ai vécu
ces deux phases là en fait pendant
l'année 2007
quand j'ai dit alors une période où la
position n'a pas de choses tout de suite
fonctionné où il y avait une perte
latente qui était assez conséquente qui
était qui était présente dans dans dans
mon compte de trading
et quand ça s'est retourné en fait fin
2007 l été 2007 où je gagne 500 millions
d'euros que je reprends une dernière
position
ils sont dans la position de 30
milliards je gagne 1 milliards de plus
gifi litres je finis 31 décembre avec un
milliard et demi de gains sachez que l
épaule et sté générale ces 1500 trader
dans le monde ça fait 3 milliards de pnb
donc je me dis moi ce que j'ai fait à
moitié de 1500 m
parce qu'il ya une phase alors je vais
revenir à la question du monsieur mais
je vais répondre à cette question en
disant que dans les phases où ça perd de
l'argent on l'attend j'étais très isolée
pour reprendre les propos de monsieur
tout à l'heure elle est à 2007 la crise
et cette prime commence d'ailleurs ça
commence par un fonds de bnp qui qui
ferme à l'époque et une crise de panique
et le marché se retourne et ses crocs
complètement c'est là que viennent les p
500 premiers millions d'euros et sur le
dernier trimestre 2007
la liquidité se disent paraît il plus
lié dit et les banques seront se feront
défiance ce ne se prêtent plus et moi
j'arrive avec un milliard et demi de
trésorerie parce que le gain cela
trésorier aussi et je refinance toute la
salle des marchés ça c'est la première
réponse à la question c'est pourquoi en
fait à ce moment-là je suis pas celui
tout monde mémoire et après je vais vous
dire autre chose c'est que le management
à l'époque et dans le système qui est
celui la salle des marchés a intérêt à
ce que je fasse le goût de l'argent et
beaucoup d'argent parce qu'en fait ils
sont indexés eux en bonus sur les stages
ne rapporte donc là en fait ce que j'ai
entendu notamment est beaucoup plus
second semestre qu'au premier sait
comment ça va mieux mais gagnent haut ce
que bien tu as fait ça vous avez tous
les jours j'avais mon manager qui
passait derrière moi qui venais marque
et faire relevé des compteurs tous les
jours j'ai une question très très
pragmatique et à celle très huppée
ensuite c'est une question dans la salle
puisque vous propose après c'est qu'on
prenne le flux de notre présentation
parce que là il ya ce qu'il ya été
beaucoup appelé l' affaire kerviel et on
en parlait tous les deux j'imagine aussi
que humainement ya sans doute une grande
lassitude de n'entendre parler que de ça
dans sa vie mais moi j'ai une question
très terre à terre parce que l'on dit
jeu
je donc tu fais ces actions et tu fais
gagner entreprises mais toi tu gagnes
pas un milliard cinq l'argent que tu
gagnes toi les bonus c'est quoi les
échelles on parle d'eux pour vous donner
une idée un fantasme de l'histoire
évidemment le trader avec un gros bonus
moi j'étais junior à l'époque donc je
n'étais pas indexé sur l'argent je
ramenais à la banque donc ça veut dire
tu gagnes quoi plus haut de l'année à
faire le plus gros que j'ai touché en
fait c'est une reste en 2007 salaire +
bonus sur 1000 euros cent mille cent
mille parcours mes managers it à 10
millions
combien dix millions dix millions voilà
c'est juste pour avoir une des échelles
et les ordres dit des sources est
intéressant peut-être prendre la
question vous avez le micro comme c'est
un refus de parler bouger ma bouche
chaud un vrai plaisir d'être en votre
compagnie je salue en particulier les
qualités d'un homme qui n'a pas peur
d'être confronté aux autres grands pins
dont on peut saluer l'intelligence
d'évidence en tout cas au plan technique
je les connais rigoureusement rien mais
ça me paraît une évidence
absolument c'est exactement ce que je
souligne j'ai eu un échange avec un
monsieur je vais chercher mon chemin
notre réaction et moi en particulier qui
suis juriste vous êtes un salarié vous
êtes en train de d'indiquer très
clairement que vous touchez mais une
infime partie des gains que votre
employeur dont votre employeur bénéficie
je voudrais savoir derrière cette
solitude j'ai très bien parfaitement
compris c'est cet aspect il est
impossible que la responsabilité de
l'ensemble j'ai bien dit l'ensemble de
vos supérieurs
nab ne soit pas retenue n'est pas été
mise en cause
rien ne pourra réparer ces
solitude dont vous parlez avec en plus
du génie derrière qui n'est pas reconnu
quand ça va pas c'est la seule question
j'ai imposé
est-ce que la responsabilité de
l'ensemble de vos employeurs de vos
supérieurs directs et tous les autres a
été retenue on est en voie d'être retenu
alors si le heureusement non car si
telle avait été car si tel avait été le
cas je n'aurais jamais été condamné
raison pour laquelle il fallait à tout
prix que je sois seul et tout seul car
j'ai été renvoyé en correctionnelle est
condamné pour abus de confiance d'abus
de confiance à partir du moment où un
des supérieurs quand la d'espèces était
informé la confiance tomber
donc en fait ils ont tous été protégé
moi c'est mon ressenti et j'ai des
éléments techniques que je peux
développer si vous souhaitez j'assiste à
un procès en appel
petite anecdote est le nombre de fois où
je pense que j'ai gagné ce dossier en 12
ans jeu c'est pareil c'est les montagnes
russes et comme le trading en fait les
moments vous avez des éléments un
témoignage vous dit c'est bon j'ai gagné
et en fait non et on est en appel en
il ya mon ancien n + 2 qui est à la
barre qui en contre interrogatoire
l'avocat de l'époque électro qu'on avait
retrouvé les protocoles transactionnels
qui ont été passés entre la banque et
ses salariés ce qu'ils ont tous été
licenciés
il ya un protocole assez grassement
payés entre les deux avec une phrase
quand on me dira toujours c'est à cette
classique dans ce genre de gros tout
comme l'interdiction de parler contre la
banque et mon avocat lui poser question
savant suivante en fait pendant le
procès monsieur à taire le nom
si vous disent que vous savez qu est ce
qui se passe c'est ce que je vous dis et
retrouvable sur les internets parce que
c'était maintenant live tweeté comme
tous les autres aussi un petit peu
médiatique la personne répond je dois
rendre l'argent que la banque m'a donné
à je me dis c'est cool j'ai gagné et on
me dit bah non en fait vous voyez par
exemple nations qui sont suivante
donc non la responsabilité de k nommée
subirait on a été engagée malgré les
nombreux éléments que soient les
protocoles transactionnels un peu
douteux qui ont été faits notamment le
dernier on se retrouve avec mon
supérieur direct qui touche beaucoup
plus que son supérieur au dessus en
transaction parce que c'est normal
c'était lui qui devait plus au contact
de moi il fallait plus les payer pour
les tenir et donc effectivement en fait
ce point là en fait été le point crucial
moi dans ma dans le process était de
démontrer en fait la connaissance de mes
supérieurs
le nombre de mails dans 17 et copie avec
noté noir sur blanc les montants et ce
que je faisais exactement ils les ont
reçus ce qu'ils sont prétendus c'est
qu'il n'avait pas lu et c'est passé vous
rigolez mais c'est passé
donc oui mais ça passe d'ailleurs
quelqu'un me disait c'est gros plus ça
passe passe et ça c'est vrai en fait
part des dernières questions 7-0 cheliff
d'autres aspects bien sûr renaud van
ruymbeke et françoise desset et charmant
alors justement on là nous sommes entrés
de plain pied mais je pense que le but
du jeu c'est vraiment cet intérêt
changer de découvrir l'autre côté des
choses donc on va passer assez vite sur
leur nom est évoqué tous ces supports la
la c'est la déclaration de du sujet là
c'est un chronogramme qui est
intéressante mais avant d'aller sur
justement
la vie après pendant toute cette époque
de 12 ans de vie énorme
j'ai deux mots que j'ai retenu en
épluchant à la fois les filles mais tout
ça il ya deux mots qui tarabuste
qu'est ce que c'est le carpet et le
spiel alors le spiel c'est faire de la
spéculation c'est vous achetez un actif
vous espérez leur endroit plus plus haut
où vous vendre un actif vous espérez
leur acheter plus bas les spéculations
tout simplement et je puisse avoir joué
en allemand c'est c'est de la
spéculation tout simplement quand on
joue normalement des règles c'était ça
ma question aussi derrière c'est lui
seul est ce que j'entends ce que j'ai vu
c'est le spiel c'est vraiment jeu ou
vers quoi on y voir une position c'est
sa maman tous à des soins de santé que
de choix donc effectivement il ya une
partie d'aléatoire ce qu'en fait il ya
quelque chose qui était leur monsieur
disait il faut toujours une part de
chance c'est vrai parce que vous
prennent position vous pouvez avoir
l'impression d'avoir un modèle
mathématique ou une stratégie graphique
en fait qui fonctionne et prendre des
positions investir en fonction de ces
éléments là il ya toujours un aléatoire
on parle et d'aléatoire thaler à table
j'adore qu'on veut pas prévoir ces deux
avions qui vont se planter dans une tour
ça vous pouvez jamais le prévoir et
alors le carpet
qu'est ce donc et le carpets est alors
en salle des marchés tout n'est pas
déclarée quand toi par exemple en fin
d'année vous avez atteindre votre
objectif est qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
comme voulait qu'on prie d'en faire plus
de ceci on va vous en demandez de faire
plus à l'épreuve et l'année suivante
c'est de mettre en réserve de l'argent
de planquer de l'argent et transféré sur
l'année suivante
si vous voulez la cdu carpet
alors justement donc l'idée aujourd'hui
n'était pas de prend que nous soyons
bien clairs aussi volontairement nous ne
prenons pas position il yal'affaire est
jugé c'est comme ça c'est
et on peut en penser ce qu'on veut il ya
justice et et jérôme va nous donner son
point de vue il ya tout l'aspect
chronologique et puis il ya des phases
très difficile dans cette histoire
l'homme en fait qu'ils devaient le plus
d'argent après une condamnation aussi ça
c'est aussi complètement exceptionnelle
à 4009 ça fait bien 10 millions 9,4
milliards 4 milliard pardon oui 4
millions encore et encore 10 jeudi et
aujourd'hui tu dois combien est
aujourd'hui s'est réduit enfin c'était
réduire 2016 à versailles d'ailleurs 1,1
million d'euros
sa fabrique un peu d'intérêt parce que
je les paye pas ils ont saisi qui sont
tous beaux et saisir en droit d'auteur
ou autres pieds depuis
y'a plus rien donc je laisse couler
heureusement j'ai des proches qui m'ont
beaucoup aidé et puis l'un vient de
monter une structure avec un de mes
collègues en fait d'apporteurs
d'affaires
donc on va danser tout au tout récent
donc on va voir comment ça se passe tu
as été condamnés par action on vit pas
on survit
en fait tu été condamné tu as aussi
gagner tu as tu as porté plainte ce que
tu as tu as obtenu une compensation pour
un licenciement alors qu'elle était
cassée mais en fait pour répondre
notamment aux prud'hommes oui en
première instance peut effectivement la
cour des prud'hommes de paris me donne
raison et voir ces cinq cent mille euros
2,2 de dommages et intérêts ils ont fait
appel de cette décision là qui a été
donc cassé en fait l'année dernière où
la vie est vrai nom enfin dire qu'on
appelle pardon on envisage là en fait
pincer en cours on a des fois on a fait
pour voir et c'est encore mais vous
savez je vais vous dire une chose très
simple même si je devais gagner cinq
cent mille euros c'est d'être confirmée
à mesure doit un million et des bananes
sera pas ce serait se seraient
compensées donc pour moi c'est
l'épaisseur du trait ou est maison
principe mais tout dans ce dossier-là
doute tout ne restera qu'une qui sont
passés de 60 ans d'oscillateurs ce que
je propose c'est que là nous nous
allions dans la douleur parler de
l'aspect technique des choses en fait de
ce qui se passait derrière et là le
voilà la vie change et de quelqu'un qui
passait sa vie derrière des écrans les
nuits les soirées là tu passes devant
l'écran comment ça se passe déjà ça fait
bizarre sur la première fois que ça vous
tombe dessus parce qu'en fait le 24
janvier 2008
donc il ya 12 ans bientôt
la façon dont j'ai appris que cette
affaire existait c'est ça votre tête
vous faire marrer mais en fait c'est à
7h30 le matin je reçois une alerte sur
mon téléphone en fait fraude assez
générale 5 milliards d'euros de pertes
et ma préparation en lisant le truc
c'est une merde les cons comment ils ont
fait et j'ai allumé la télé j'ai vu ma
tête est là en fait j'ai rien compris à
ce qui s'est passé après derrière ça a
été un emballement en fait j'ai rien
compris à ce qui se passait c'est un
emballement médiatique de dingue
ok je n'étais absolument pas préparés
j'ai passé quasiment un mois en fait à
fuir les photographes les journalistes
et paparazzi qui me suivait donc après
on nous apprend à vivre avec ça petit à
petit on devient un petit peu malin et
on apprend à être quelques ruses de
sioux
et puis on a des réseaux après qu'ils
nous informent heureusement donc le
premier contact avec les médias moi
c'était vivantes ici
quand j'ai vu la faute de la tête de mon
badge la télé je petit roots je crois
que je le remets en fait et je pars en
fait un vrai cauchemar
et en fait non c'était la réalité et et
après en fait paradoxalement gt2 ou
choquer je trouve qu assez rapidement
gtd placé en détention préventive à la
prison de la santé
et finalement c'est le recul ça m'a fait
du bien en fait ça m'a fait une pause
seulement et surtout de me poser demain
de me dire ok là au moins on en fait je
suis peinard j'ai le temps de me poser
de faire raconter mes orteils et de voir
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
alors en fait le plus dur dans cette
période là c'est pas tant pour
évidemment c'est violent pour les
personnes qui les vignes en fait pour
moi c'est pas ça qui était plus lent
c'est surtout l'impact sur les proches
parce qu'on prête on développe stabilité
par rapport aux proches qui eux sont
dehors et qui doit subir ce battage
médiatique sur tout mais à l'époque ma
mère était encore en vie donc je
m'inquiétais beaucoup pour elle et
surtout on se demande qu'est ce que les
gens pensent le regard des autres
évidemment qu'on y pense régulièrement
et
et voilà et donc le bois non c'est un
peu violent donc là je propose qu'on
reste sur la dimension humaine justement
donc la dette des bouleversements d un
petit fond une tornade et après d'autres
moments circle hack tu prends la route
qu'est ce qui se passe là dans ta tête
quel est le leur sort le cheminement
on est en 2014 donc on est six ans après
avec la bonne affaire je me suis fait
condamner
une fois en première instance à cinq ans
de prison trois ferme et 5 milliards de
dommages-intérêts 2012 rebelote
confirmés ont déposé plainte ont
commencé dans une vraie monde guérilla
judiciaire avec la sté générale en
déposant des plaintes dans tous les sens
et puis il ya quelque chose qui est
important dans mon dossier
c'est qu'en fait je suis accusé depuis
douze ans au fait d'avoir fait perdre 5
milliards d'euros à sté générale et
depuis douze ans que ce soit instruction
avec renaud van ruymbeke
mais y compris au moment des procès ou d
eau d instruction qui ont eu lieu à la
faveur des plaintes que j'ai pu déposer
g de cesse que de demander une seule
chose une expertise indépendante
pascal date je n'ai pas la moindre
preuve que c'était gérard a perdu 5
milliards d'euros si ce n'est leurs
déclarations ou depuis 12 ans je réclame
cette expertise et à ce moment là en
2014 en fait j'avais un bon espoir parce
qu'il ya un jeune garçon qui s'appelle
roger le loire qui avait pris en charge
l'instruction d'un dossier sur laquelle
j'étais moi en fait j'ai dont j'avais
déposé plainte
j'étais partie civile est en fait il me
refuse expertise nouvelle fois donc là
je suis un peu au fond du trou parce
qu'en fait évidemment une morale fait un
peu les montagnes russes dans ces
moments là parce qu'en fait on a de
l'espoir et après ces déçus c'est un peu
plus compliqué de remonter et jeté un
puck au fond du trou et je m'apprête
humaniste et un vendredi une de mes amis
m'appellent sachant la nouvelle me dit
viens d'avoir un verre on prend un verre
j'étais au fond du seau mon avocat m'a
pen dit man savage moyens jeudi de quoi
tu as besoin de lui répondre un miracle
il me répond pourquoi trip hop hop
j'ai peut-être ma gueule seront plus
puis comme michael je ne sais pas
déconner je suis catholique croyant en
la pratiquant mais croyant le pape
françois venez d'être élu et on se
décide enfin je décide le week end
commence à écrire une lettre qui a été
relu avec les avocats ils nous ont aidés
en fait c'est un travail collectif
une fois que cette lettre a été écrite
ces merdes comment c'est quoi l'adresse
est ce que le pape le vatican ça reste
pas arrivé et l'a en fait il ya le la
magie de ce que ce genre de vie ce genre
de dossier peut vous qu'il peut créer on
a eu beaucoup dans douze ans de beaux
moments
un journaliste suisse qui s'appelle
arnaud bédat des bars dont le bureau en
fait ils revêtent bouna sarr s il est un
bouquin sur le sur le tapis il renonce
bureau en bureau de mon avocat ce moment
là est dit ou fait quoi et ben ali il
n'a rien dit je voulais je la fais
passer dit oui et c'est comme ça je me
retrouvais vatican grâce à lui et en
fait il ya une première fois nous sommes
rendus à rome sa la rencontre n'a pas
fonctionné à paris cette affaire je suis
reparti à paris la semaine suivante on a
rappelé le dip revenez et un peu pour
créer sa chance parce que je ne pensais
pas que ça allait se produire cette
rencontre j'étais très dubitatif et dans
l'avion pour nous amener à rome ont
aucun en fait je dis à mon avocat si ça
se fait et david koubbi à l'époque c'est
david koubbi je lui dis si ça se fait je
rentre à pied mais genre de paris à la
con quoi
donc la photo en bas à droite en fait
montre qu'on s'est rencontrés on a pu
échanger et il rentre à l'hôtel mont à
mon avocat il doit y avoir des cyclos
cour de cassation qui devait tomber et
ma came dit on rentre même si banon dit
qu'on sait maintenant comment ça nous
dit mais en fait ce qu'on se dit je
rentre à pied
oubliez partie moi je le jure et ses
arômes trois quatre jours pour bien
comprendre reconnais que j'étais en
train de faire
et puis à lundi matin je me suis dit si
je peux encore me levant je partirai
jamais j'ai pris mon sac à dos et j'ai
commencé à marcher
et puis ça a duré quelques mois c'était
un des plus beaux moments de ma vie donc
la question la question que je ne
poserai pas c'est qu'elle échange ale
qu'est ce que vous essayez seule
question le joker
j'ai une pensée qui me venaient en
voyant la photo précédente c'est que on
se détendre tout petit peu peut-être que
tu aurais pu déposer des droits sur la
parka rouge parce que ça a été repris
fin ça a été utilisé par donner sens et
s était fait pour d'autres rencontres
puisque moi j'ai eu le plaisir de voir
le film et non pas en préparation
qu'est ce que ça fait de ce qu'il
utilise en plus ton nom dans le film
gérante carrière quelle est la part
véracité d'anciennes comment tu l'a
aperçu tu l'as vu déjà enfin j'imagine
oui j'ai vu mais c'est là pour voir un
film je vous parlais à christophe en
fait qui est devenu un ami et on a
beaucoup travaillé parce qu'il voulait
s'imprégner participe à tous les procès
des trois dire son nom c'est ça
barratier barratier du calife ali
choriste avant et
en fait c'est très dur en fait la
première fois que j'ai vu le film ça me
fait un vrai choc parce qu'en fait
effectivement quand on l'entend son nom
à l'écran c'est bien un truc un peu
schizophrénique dans l'histoire mais non
sur la partie sur la partie évidemment
ça commençait sur la partie vie privée
ainsi de suite
il ya plein de scènes qui n'ont pas
digéré pas mangé un poisson ou mort je
n'ai pas mangé de poisson rouge et mais
sur l'aspect ambiance salle de marché et
finalement d'une certaine façon il a
ramassé 88 ans de 8 ans de vie en fait
en une heure et quelques et je trouve
que c'est plutôt pas mal réalisé way et
après pour moi c'est super compliqué de
juger cela parce que j'ai pas le recul
nécessaire en fait j'ai plus de recul
nouvelle question et ensuite nous allons
alors j'ai eu le oui on et j'apprends
petit à petit et il se trouve que j'ai
eu le bonheur d'avoir une petite fille
il ya 18 mois donc effectivement ça me
remet dans la vie ces genres de choses
qui me remettre dans la vie tout à fait
on pourrait imaginer que ça serve de
leçon puisque c'est une affaire
complètement exceptionnelle avec puisque
ce que j'ai cru comprendre aussi c'est
que certains ça arrive à d'autres
traders peut-être pas sur les mêmes
montants parce que la thur engagé
jusqu'à combien de sommes au mois de
janvier on était à 50 me à 50 milliards
finalement c'est c'est un grosse pile la
cijp il ya mai et alors il faut il faut
quand même qu'on bien comprendre que ce
sont des produits dérivés dont qui a pas
50 milliards d'euros qui sera sorti les
caisses de la banque un ce qu'on a fait
les produits dérivés donc en fait il ya
juste le dépôt de garantie qu'on peut te
prend des poses et dépôts garantis il
doit être autour de 5% du montant des
sommes donc ça fait de mal et c'est déjà
du sol mais c'est parce qu'ils sont si
le gars de préciser parce que pour
vraiment personnage complètement
standard
c'est délirant ses valeurs et ses sables
visiblement sur le marché sap a vraiment
servi de leçon puisque là il n'a fait
assez récente particulier où elle vous
en aurez d'autres c'est inhérent au
business model et sa démarche et j'ai
envie de dire
et puis même jeu pour être transparents
et vous je rencontrais quelqu'un à
l'autre jour de commandes des services
de contrôle la sté générale qui malade
dans la rue et qui me dit je vais
démissionner parce qu'en fait en
l'occurrence tout ce qu on a annoncé
qu'on allait faire parce qu'en fait vous
savez il ya un truc qui était pour moi
très utile dans ce dans ce dossier parce
que ce sont des gens qui sont venus me
parler au moment où la faire éclater
parce qu'ils se sont sentis insultés et
jean des services de pointe rouge parce
que ils ont fait leur job
et quand on dit que les salaisons
contrôler la cité nantes était
défaillant eux sont montés insulté et
certains d'entre eux ont éprouvé le
besoin de nous rejoindre défense pour
dire non on a fait notre job en fait
c'est des gens très bien payé si en plus
on nous insulte ça marche pas et donc je
croisais l'un d'entre eux en fait il ya
quelques semaines qui me disaient que
tout ce qu'ils avaient annoncé au niveau
de changement dans les procédures la sté
générale contrôle des traders
n'existaient pas c'était de la
communication ces raisons traquer le
parterre la banque et que l'activité
pour les traders que je croise
aujourd'hui me disent que les attendent
la prochaine crise avec impatience parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils vont se gaver
penser que ça va changer
non moi je suis convaincu que ça va
changer les échos que j'en ai en fait
vont dans ce sens là
et on va revenir en arrière en ce moment
samar quand vous voyez sur votre
téléphone portable qu'une espèce
d'anguille a téléphoné à satiété rien et
là tout le déferlement
comment est ce que vous avez réussi à
vous organiser un entourage qui à un
moment donné
cicas mais comment elle s'est parfois
derrière quand on s'y attend pas comment
est ce que vous avez réussi en commet là
comment est-ce que qui vise à aider à
vous entourer pour traverser stable
alors déjà au début vous voulez ses
portes et vous comprenez ne pas bien
s'il est en train de nous arriver parce
que je vais vous dire une chose
évidemment le avant que l'annoncent de
la médiatique de jeudi 24 janvier
évidemment je vais passer un week end
pseudo garde à vue interne de la banque
est une forme de mise à pied on dit on
me dit en partant le dimanche revient
pas lundi on te rappelles et donc du
lundi au jeudi l' annonce en fait je
n'ai aucune nouvelle
si ce n'est que potentiellement j'ai un
prix donne en fait qui va arriver et
donc je prends une à l'époque prévention
que les conseils de mon frère jeudi un
avocat comment sait jamais quand
j'appelle une personne qui était
spécialisé en droit du travail
je m'explique le dossier puis elle me
dit où la jaille à la veille dans ce
merdier score me dis ouais j'ai lu votre
père vous m'écoutez rappelez moi quand
vous recevez votre lettre de
licenciement
et puis on verra on traite on traite ça
des vous avez ça ok dont le lendemain ça
pète
je rappelle adam j'ai eu je crois que
notre problème assez voulzy oui c'est
moi donc vous porter justement kevin est
donc je suis content et tout de suite à
son cabinet
le temps de faire comprendre ce qui est
en train de se dérouler de répondre
aussi aux attaques parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de rumeurs qui circulaient il y
avait une rumeur qui fait naître
gouvernement le gouverneur de la banque
de france
je suis noyé qui avait déclaré que
j'étais en fuite ce qui est complètement
faux
et donc il y avait un rouleau
compresseur en fait médiatique et puis
un storytelling mis en place par la
banque
comment ça se déroule avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de conneries y compris des
conneries personnel j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est ça qui est plus blaise mans
parce que là ils vont chercher n'importe
qui pour parler de vous et je voyais des
interviews de gens que je crois qu'il
parlait de moi c'est ça qui est assez
particulier donc à ce moment là en fait
vous parer au plus pressé trouver un
avocat
essayez de mettre en place une stratégie
essayer d'expliquer aussi le dossier
l'avocat parce que c'est un peu
technique et c'est pas commun et puis
après vous gérer au plus pressé en fait
et après c'est avec le temps passant au
début j'ai évidemment fait énormément
d'erreurs
j'aurai encore j'imagine y compris
médiatique
sachant que je me suis comme vachement
protégées au début je n'ai pas parlé aux
médias pendant plus d'un an
donc j'ai eu le temps de m'y habituer de
me préparer de déjà d'intégrer le fait
que je devais y incarner un personnage
qui n'était plus celui qui était trader
à l'époque que c'était ma vie d'avant a
été ma vie d'avant qui n'existerait plus
jamais et encore une fois je pense aux
ce qui m'a sauvé c'est que tout ce que
je pouvais imaginer à l'époque était
très loin de ce qui sépare revenu par la
suite notamment la prison je n'avais pas
anticipé cette arrivée est en fait c'est
du cas par cas
c'est au gré des événements je me suis
adapté et j'ai eu la chance aussi d'être
très bien entourée par des amies
ils sont beaucoup moins nombreux
qu'avant parce que bizarrement fait les
vols d'étourneaux s est reproduit un
genre de cas mais il ya une nouvelle
rencontre s'il ya des belles surprises
et
et ça c'est quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup aidé dans les années qui ont
passé depuis nous ont effectivement
d'avoir des gens autour de moi qui sont
assez exceptionnelles et qui sont
vraiment présent et qui moment mon
antidépresseur ce mes potes en fait
prendre une dernière question et puis
nous allons conclure parce que l'une des
promesses du club c'est de te lire
timing on est légèrement décalé de cinq
minutes
dernière question et j'ai une question
de conclusion bien sûr non absolument
pas vous savez en fait je j'ai fait j'ai
fait une connerie une connerie je le
reconnais je suis laissé embarquer dans
un dans un schéma en fait qui était une
fuite en avant
mais si vous savez en fait je vais
nuancé ma réponse en me disant je
regrette pour les gens qui n'ont rien
demandé et qui ont souffert de cette
histoire que ce soit les proches est
probalement d'autres personnes par
ailleurs je regrette pour ça après d'un
point de vue purement humain je suis
plus heureux aujourd'hui que je n'ai
jamais été avant j'ai rencontré des gens
formidables géophysique tendance dure et
qui m'ont enrichi aussi qui m'ont
endurci
il m'a appris beaucoup de choses qui me
fait ouvrir les yeux sur pas mal de
choses aussi après l'erreur entre moi et
moi je la gère au quotidien et la seule
chose que je puisse vous dire c'est que
maintenant courir dans la glace depuis
12 ans en fait j'ai aucun problème avec
ça
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une dernière question donc tu as
écrit un livre et kid en titre et
j'aurais pu passer à côté de ma vie
alors c'est un peu énigmatique est ce
que ça ses réponses à répondre un peu à
qui sont de monsieur c'est à dire que en
fait effectivement je ne me rendais plus
grande que j'étais une certaine façon et
par ma propre foi parce que c'est on a
toujours nos choix et on a notre propre
arbitre un laissé le goût tamisée par un
système par un métier qui était ma
passion et je l'exercé à outrance
pendant plusieurs années et je me suis
perdu dans ce métier là et j'étais
complètement coupé du monde
je m'étais éloigné ma famille mes amis
et malheureusement il faut souvent que
la ligue et des épreuves et des drames
entre guillemets pour prendre conscience
mais il aura fallu celui là pour prendre
conscience et en prennent prendre
pleinement conscience
à tel point que aujourd'hui ce qui me
plaît c'est ce genre des changes
rencontrer des gens apprendre de ces
gens et vivre des expériences un peu
hors norme par moments la marche pour
moi c'était quelque chose qui n'était
pas du tout dans mes habitudes et j'ai
fait mika sans bornes en italien et j'ai
pris un pied monumental à le faire sama
ressources et ça m'a appris sur moi ça
m'a fait découvrir autre chose et on
entend des gens fabuleux sur nos sur la
route
voilà c'est aujourd'hui je me suis
beaucoup plus riches
intérieurement j'ai l'impression d'avoir
eu dix mille vies dans une vie et même
la période de prison en fait nous n'est
pas un mauvais souvenir
paradoxalement en tout cas merci
infiniment parce que persée
[Applaudissements]